this is a view from Alan's window and
this is a view from Jane's window when
we were stuck inside during covid window
swapping became a thing where you can
share the view of your window all over
the world for a few minutes you can feel
like you're in someone else's home and
there's a feeling of connection with
that other person imagine you're in a
Mars habitat and there's one module that
stimulates what living in a living room
would look like on Earth with a standard
furniture and an LCD window showing
different views of the world accompanied
by a surround sound system that
simulates all of the sounds coming from
it depending on the shape size and
height the windows can change our
relationship to the outside this is
designed to bring in daylight and this
frames a specific element in the view
and I think for these astronauts it does
more than this it shortens a
psychological distance between us and
the planet from a place of fear to a
place that we can inhabit